les parlementaires conçu une petite
dizaine une dizaine de leurs parrainages
arena j'avais mal macron parce que je le
redis c'est qu'ils connaissent la
plupart d'entre eux ce sont des
camarades qui eux connaissent les
statuts du parti socialiste
ils sont pas ignorants donc je leur dis
ben voila tu connais les statuts tu t'es
mis dans la situation de contrevenir à
nos statuts et donc tu peux plus
représenter le parti socialiste et du
coup est ce que c'est est ce que c'est
une sanction pour vous ce crâne ne plus
représenter le parti socialiste c'est
une sanction est une sanction plus
sévère a quand même un bas pour ceux qui
sont candidats aux législatives c'est
assez compliqué moi je me rappelle qu'il
ya peu de temps vous parliez même
d'exclure non j'ai jamais dit l'exclure
vous savez je fais très attention à ce
que je dis dans ce domaine vous savez je
n'ai pas exclu les frondeurs qui étaient
favorables au dépôt d'une motion de
censure contre leur propre gouvernement
et qui partait de participer à des
manifestations
manifestation excusez moi assez violente
contre le gouvernement j'ai dit que la
question de leur appartenance au groupe
socialiste au parti socialiste serait
posée si cette motion était déposée
jeudi de la même façon que je ne sont
pas les reins et les coeurs et les états
d'âme des uns et des autres mais que si
on part elle qu'elle tient un petit un
adversaire de notre candidat c'est la
même chose donc à chaque fois je fixe
des limites tout en comprenant les
interrogations les réflexions parce que
moi je ne suis pas un et curateurs je
suis un rassembleur et je comprends
qu'on puisse s'interroger mais je dis à
tout le monde il faut se rassembler